se trata de un grupo paramilitar muy
hermético supremacistas organizados en
milicias antigubernamentales se hacen
llamar o skippers los guardias del
juramento este grupo de extrema derecha
estaba en la primera línea del asalto al
Capitolio al lado de otros movimientos
extremistas como coanon creado en 2009
en sus inicios off keepers se defendía
como un grupo de defensa de la
constitución pero enseguida se
radicalizó
al principio era un grupo de personas
que se definían como amantes de la
Constitución y que querían que sus
principios se respetaran pero
internamente las conversaciones eran
cada vez más violentas y empezaron a
considerar al gobierno como un enemigo
tirano que quiere desarmar los
ciudadanos y vulnerar la segunda
enmienda un Grupo Violento dispuesto a
derrocar la administración
estadounidense estructurado alrededor de
su fundador Steward roads el pasado mes
de julio delante del senado el
exportavoz del movimiento dibujó un
retrato inquietante de la organización
una milicia peligrosa se nutre en gran
parte del ego sobredimensionado de
Stuart roads
Él se ve como un líder paramilitar para
mí es una organización peligrosa
distintos miembros de la organización
incluido su fundador hoy están siendo
procesados por la justicia
estadounidense acusados de complottis
edición contra el estado enfrentan hasta
20 años de